نذهب الى نجوان سمري من تل ابيب وعن هذه
التصريحات التي
نقلها مصدر دبلوماسي لجوروس بوست عن بعض
ما قاله بنامينا نتنياهو للرئيس الامريكي
بان اطلاق نحو 100 صاروخ من غزه يستوجب
ردا هل هناك معلومات اكثر حول
لماذا تقوم اسرائيل في لحظات من التهدئه
بعمليه من هذا النوع وبهذا الحجم
نعم عمليا كان هذا متوقع عبد السلام
لاسيما وانه بعد يوم الثلاثاء الماضي وبعد
ان تم اطلاق اكثر من 100 قذيفه وصاروخ من
قطاع غزه باتجاه غلاف غزه والمستوطنات
الاسرائيليه المحيطه بقطاع غزه كاشارت
غالبيه التقديرات الامنيه والعسكريه في
اسرائيل الى انه سيكون هناك رد بعمليه
عسكريه لكن اسرائيل تنتظر الوقت المناسب
الذي تحدده بنفسها كما اشار في حينه
العديد من المحللين الامنيين والعسكريين
في الجانب الاسرائيلي بخصوص اطلاع الاداره
الامريكيه على هذه العمليه اشارت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه بانه بالفعل تم اطلاع
الاداره الامريكيه على هذه العمليه وبان
اسرائيل سترد على
اطلاق الصواريخ من غزه الاسبوع الماضي
باستهداف قاده سرايا القدس الذراع العسكري
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي وتم وصف ذلك بانها
ستكون عمليه محدوده فقط لاستهداف قاده
سرايا الجهاد الاسلامي وان اسرائيل ربما
لا ترغب
بالشروع بمعركه شامله او بحرب واسعه وانما
فقط عمليه محدوده كرد على اطلاق الصواريخ
لكن بالاضافه الى الاهداف العسكريه التي
يتم التطرق اليها باستهداف القاده
العسكريين لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي لابد من
الاشاره ايضا الى ان
المراقبون الاسرائيليون يتحدثون بان
الاهداف الحقيقيه لهذه العمليه هي ليست
الاهداف العسكريه وانما اهداف توصف بانها
عاطفيه او اهداف معنويه وتتلخص اولا
بتحقيق ما يوصف باسرائيل
الردع التي تاكلت في الاونه الاخيره حيث
وجهت انتقادات واسعه لرئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو بانه تسبب بعدم الرد في
عده مناسبات واحداث قد حصلت في الاشهر
الاخيره الماضيه تحديدا في فتره عيد الفصح
اليهودي سواء كان من قبل الجانب في قطاع
غزه واطلاق عده قذائف صاروخيه وايضا من
الجانب اللبناني عندما اطلقت ايضا عده
قذائف صاروخيه باتجاه الحدود الشماليه
والجانب الاسرائيلي بانه مسؤول عن تاكل
قوه الردع وبان اسرائيل عليها ان تخوض
عمليه عسكريه واسعه لاعاده قوه الردع هذا
من جهه من جهه اخرى يقال بان هذه العمليه
كانت بالاساس ايضا
تهدف لمنع عمليات
مقاومين فلسطينيين تحديدا في الضفه
الغربيه المستوطنين وضده
اهداف اسرائيليه بتوجيه من قاده الجهاد
الاسلامي في غزه والهدف الثالث بطبيعه
الحال هو الانتقام من اقبال الفصائل
الفلسطينيه فصائل المقاومه باطلاق هذا
الكم الكبير من الصواريخ والقذائف الاسبوع
الماضي باتجاه مستوطنات غلاف غزه لاسيما
وان اسرائيل من جهه قالت بان حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي كانت هي المسؤوله عن اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ ولكنها ايضا لم تبرئ حركه
المقاومه حماس من المسؤوليه ومن درايتها
ومعرفتها بان الجهاد الاسلامي يقوم بذلك
وبالتالي ايضا حملت حركه حماس المسؤوليه
عن اطلاق الصواريخ لكن هناك هدف اخر يتم
التحدث عنه ايضا في الجانب الاسرائيلي وهو
حل الازمه الداخليه
لبنيامين نتنياهو مع تحديدا
عظمه يهوديه برئاسه وقياده وزير الامن
الاسرائيلي الداخلي المتطرف لتمر بن جبير
والذي اعلن عن مقاطعه جلسات الكنيست
والحكومه وعدم التصويت الى جانب قوانين
حكوميه وهذا اجراء استثنائي بشكل عام من
قبل وزير في الحكومه بني جفير هدده
بمقاطعه التصويت على قوانين حكوميه
وبالفعل اقدم على ذلك خلال الاسبوع الاخير
بعد ان اتهم ايضا
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بالتراخي بالرد على
اطلاق الصواريخ من غزه من جهه يحاول بني
كبير الترويج بان هذه العمليه كانت ربما
لارضائه والتجاوب مع مطالبه بالعوده
للتصويت الى هذه القوانين بعد ان تقدم
حقوق الحكومه الاسرائيليه على مثل هذه
العمليه سواء كان في غزه او في الضفه
الغربيه كانت له شروط عده لكن من جهه اخرى
يقال ايضا بانه لم يتم اطلاعه اطلاقا على
هي العمليه خوفا ان يقوم بالتسريب لوسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه بان اسرائيل مقبله على
تنفيذ هذه العمليه التي اقرت يوم الجمعه
الماضي من قبل رئيس الحكومه اثناء زياره
له لمقر الامن الداخلي العام الشابات في
يوم الجمعه الماضي بكل الاحوال هنا حاله
ترقب كبيره على المستوى السياسي والامني
الاسرائيلي هل سيكون هناك رد من سيشارك في
هذا الرد والمجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر
لشؤون السياسيه والامنيه سيجتمع مساء هذا
اليوم هنا في مدينه تل ابيب عند الخامسه
مساء لبحث ربما امكانيات الرد المحتمله من
قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه وربما ايضا من قبل
جبهات اخرى وعند الثامنه مساء سيكون هناك
تصريح ستكون هناك تصريحات مشتركه لوزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي جالنتي الى جانب رئيس
الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو للحديث عن
مستجدات الوضع الامني بعد هذه العمليه عبد
السلام